il est de mon avis que vouloir apprendre
apprendre et savoir utiliser le savoir
pour continuer à réfléchir
c'est très important et je vous invite
tous dans la mesure du possible
passer toute votre vie à apprendre et à
réussir ce savoir je vais illustrer ce
cette pensée avec la nourriture 1.0 qui
essentiellement vous explique comment
j'ai fait il traditions alimentaires et
je suis devenu végétalien avant de
devenir végétalien j'étais comme la
plupart d'entre vous j'en suis sûr
quelqu'un qui avait une alimentation
variée équilibrée a priori et je
consommer de la viande vers 17 ans l'âge
où j'ai commencé à avoir envie de de
faire des expériences de changer j'ai
décidé suite à aux conseils de ma soeur
qui elle avait alors 15 ans de devenir
végétalien elle aussi en même temps que
moi est devenu un peu avant est devenue
végétalienne
elle m'a notamment convaincu par de très
nombreux documentaires le premier temps
qu'à ou spear et si le premier a retenu
parle des relations des humains avec les
autres animaux sur terre battue guerre
film du sucre sans forcément de
végétaliens mais des conséquences du sud
qui soit artificiel ou naturel et aussi
comment en trop grande quantité il peut
avoir des conséquences plus que le
surpoids mais c'est grâce à ma soeur que
j'ai vu la majorité de ces films est ko
sur et si le premier qu'elle va montrer
a suffi à me convaincre de l'intérêt de
du végétalisme et du jour au lendemain
je suis devenu végétalien le lendemain
d'avoir vu ce film j'ai raté la viande
j'arrêtais les produits laitiers les
oeufs et tous qui dérivent des animaux
ma soeur quant à elle avait déjà fait
deux expériences de où ils avaient été
veillés italienne avec une amie pendant
une certain un certain temps mais ça
n'avait pas tenu et sinon vous pouvez
évidemment prendre un planning bien
bien réguliers par exemple en un mois a
arrêté la viande le mois suivant arrêté
le fromage le mois d'après les produits
laitiers et saisira les coûts rapidement
je vais parler de quelques conséquences
sur ma personne et mes activités après
avoir fait cette transition
la première est encore deux semaines
j'ai perdu quatre kilos
pourtant je mangeais plus ceci
s'explique parce que tous les aliments
pour un même volume n'ont pas le même en
aux calories vous voyez tout à gauche
que 400 calories de fruits et de légumes
remplissent un estomac et donc vous
donner un sentiment de ne plus avoir
faim la fin du repas alors que 400
calories de viande nous remplissent qu'à
moitié d'estomac et l'huile pas du tout
donc plus vous mangez de de produits
animaux enfin par l'ulm et de viande et
de fromage
plus vous vous serez enclin à manger
trop de calories autres
conséquence que j'ai remarqué c'est de
nombreuses personnes me demandent si
quand même on peut sortir ensemble et
aller dans un resto oui parce que c'est
pas très compliqué de trouver quelque
chose qui avec une large panoplie de
choix mais aussi de temps en temps je
peux me permettre un petit écart si des
fois je lave ou par gourmandise mais des
fois par par praticité et avec dans un
restaurant je peux très bien manger des
légumes avec une crème si le restaurant
ne propose rien de végétaliens dernière
conséquence mon transit intestinal a
beaucoup changé
je n'ai depuis deux ans et demi où j'ai
fait sa transition je n'ai eu aucun
souci et je m'assois au moins deux fois
par jour aux toilettes
voilà maintenant j'aimerais vous inviter
à j'aimerais vous inviter dans le
domaine que représente le domaine
agroalimentaire parce que j'étais
collard et les documentaires dont vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure que c'est un
domaine très peu connu et qui présente
beaucoup de faits intéressants
commençons tout d'abord par la question
que tout le monde se pose quand je leur
en parle généralement si je des carences
et d'où je tiens les protéines
je n'ai aucune carence j'ai fait un des
prises de sang je n'ai pas de carence en
fer pas de carence en protéines et le
taux de gras dans mon sang est très bas
donc le risque de maladies
cardiovasculaires le
quant aux protéines les viandes la
viande contient certes des protéines
mais pour une même quantité de lentilles
et de viande
il y aura plus de protéines dans les
lentilles que de n'importe quel bien les
protéines et animales sont différents de
protéines végétales
mais notre mais surtout par leur
différence graisseuse essentiellement
les seuls protéines dont nous avons
fondamentalement besoin pour vivre se
trouve dans les végétaux les protéines
animales que nous consommons amène non
seulement la protéine que dans notre
corps a besoin mais en plus du gras dans
notre organisme
ce gr se retrouvent dans notre sens est
la principale cause des arrêts
cardiaques ou des attaques cardiaques
dans notre roman occidental
les maladies cardiovasculaires sont le
premier sont la première cause de
mortalité en occident est ce que nous
faisons pour combler une attaque
cardiaque
ce n'est pas changer de régime
alimentaire ou ferr ou d'une autre chose
c'est simplement prendre une veine
artificielle ou non et l'a remplacée sur
la veine boucher parce que là vienne se
bouche de gras et au lieu de résoudre le
problème
on remet le problème à plus tard en
remettant à une autre veine sûr aussi
les problèmes les problèmes que l'on
peut avoir avec les ans qu'on se demande
en sueur consommant des produits animaux
et c'est par rapport à aux produits
laitiers
mon grand père avait des problèmes de
prostate il a arrêté de manger des
produits laitiers et tous ces problèmes
se sont résolus il n'a plus aucun
problème de prostate et même il dit se
retrouver comme quand il avait 40 ans le
il existe aussi des cas avéré de
personnes qui avaient un cancer en phase
terminale et qui ne pouvait plus être
guéri enfin qu'il pouvait plus de
traiter pardon parce que le risque
aurait été trop grand on n'était pas
assez forte pour pouvoir résister aux
traitements
ces personnes ont arrêté de manger des
produits animaux et ont guéri on soigner
leur cancer et sont toujours aujourd'hui
vivante et en pleine forme
dernière chose encore sur les humains
nous avons la nourriture que nous
mangeons a une influence à long terme
petit à petit tous les efforts que nous
demandons à notre corps se répercute sur
notre corps plus âgés et pour cela je
vais vous proposer un petit jeu voici
annette larkins elle habite aux états
unis quel âge lui donneriez-vous une
réponse elle n'a pas 18 ans dont sept
personnes et les italiennes depuis très
longtemps et bon j'ai beaucoup de c2c de
ces aliments crus sans les faire cuire
elle a 73 ans dans cette photo
encore une fois liam cunningham un
acteur irlandais assez connus qui à 56
ans on voit une nette différence au
niveau des rides au niveau des de
l'expression et dernier exemple elle
voit recevoir à lui aussi américain pas
connu c'est un c'était un travail encore
c'était un cardiologue qui a opéré
jusqu'à sa retraite
une idée sur la photo leïla 98 il a
arrêté d'être des chirurgiens à 95 ans
il est encore vivant aujourd'hui il
lance en trois ans il est né en 1914 il
a fait la guerre mondiale la seconde
guerre mondiale et il a été végétalien
pendant plus de la moitié de sa vie
je vais maintenant vous parler des de l'
influence que un régime végétalien peut
avoir sur d'autres aspects pas seulement
sur notre corps est le premier c'est sur
l'environnement sur l'eau nous ne sommes
plus de 7.5 milliards sur terre et l'eau
devient indoor est de plus en plus rares
vous voyez sur le premier graphique que
pour produire un seul kilo de boeuf il
faut plus de quinze mille litres d'eau
alors que les deux derniers les deux
dernières les donner un petit frère ou
présente les fruits les légumes une
moyenne leboeuf et toutes les viandes
sont excessivement vorace quand cinq ans
en quantité d'eau pour vous donner
meilleure idée un seul burger ça
représente trois mois de douche lalo que
vous consommez en trois mois de douche
c'est idiot que vous consommez en
mangeant un seul béria et cela se
répercute sur la consommation d'eau
mondial dans le monde 70 % de l'eau
consommée c'est l'industrie
agroalimentaire et uniquement celle-là
19% c'est pour le reste de l'industrie
et 11% inclut toute l'eau que l'on
consomme en se douchant en buvant en
lavant notre voiture à la piscine ou
toute autre activité
il ne faut pas non plus négliger les
autres facteurs par exemple deux mille
cinq cents vaches produisent autant de
déchets que 400 que quatre cent onze
mille personnes
c'est à dire dix mille vaches c'est les
déchets de lyon et marseille combiner
les la deuxième et troisième villes
françaises pour pousser encore un peu
les chiffres la population française de
65 millions de personnes produit autant
de déchets plus 400 mille vaches en
france nous avons 20 millions de vaches
l'industrie agro alimentaire des animaux
quand ici c'est tout ce qu'ils dérivent
de l'un d'eux de l'industrie agro
alimentaire c'est-à-dire le
le coup en gaz à effet de serre de la
production de nourriture du transport de
nourriture jusqu'aux animaux de du rejet
de gaz à effet de serre pendant la
croissance des animaux et tout jusqu'à
l'abattage et jusqu'à temps que ça
arrive dans votre assiette
tout ça ça représente 51 % des émissions
des gaz à effet de serre le transport
mondial que ce soit de personnes ou de
marchandises et se monte à 13%
dernier aspect à ne pas négliger c'est
la déforestation au brésil 91% de la
déforestation se fait pour avoir de la
place pour ou faire pousser de la nature
pour les vaches ou pour enfin avoir de
la place pour les vaches en elle même la
production mondiale
non là là par la part de déforestation
qui réellement utilisés pour le papier
ou ses produits dérivés dans le monde
c'est 6%
rapidement cette surconsommation
cette pollution a une influence aussi
sur les animaux eux-mêmes les vaches
notamment aux états unis où on les
nourrit de maïs qui n'est pas leur
aliment de base ont souvent des
problèmes gastriques et nécessite
beaucoup de médicaments ce qui détériore
potentiellement la qualité de leur lait
aussi une vache peut espérer vivre si on
la laissait tranquille entre guillemets
18 à 20 ans une vache passe trois ans
dans une usine allait avant de mourir
d'épuisement
enfin un dernier fait que j'ai trouvé
très intéressant c'est que évolution'
mans nous ne sommes pas faits pour
manger de la viande
vous voyez la dentition d'un tigre avec
des de très larges câline fait pour
accrocher la veille et une proie d'un
beau ghoudane ours des omnivores avérée
ou enfin d'un cheval avec ses dents
plate
nous avons certes des canines meinau
canine ne sont pas gigantesques de danse
ont globalement plate l'uniforme fait
pour mastiquer
cette dentition ne permet pas la
consommation de viande ne permet pas ne
permettrait pas théoriquement une
consommation de viande que nous la
consommons aujourd'hui mais nous devions
au plus à l'état naturel
autre argument assez intéressant c'est
que le petit intestin tous les deux
carnivores et des omnivores fait 3,6
fois la longueur de leur trou ceci est
pour éviter que la nourriture ne
pourrisse pendant le transit
notre intestin comme tous ceux des
herbivores d'autres petites incessamment
comme tous ceux d arvor fait 10 à 12
fois la longueur de notre corps six à
sept mètres
j'étais venu ici pour vous apprendre
quelque chose ou si vous le saviez déjà
vous divertir et vous remémorer des
faits
j'espère que c'est chose faite et
j'espère que dans un futur plus ou moins
lointain
vous seriez en mesure de à votre tour
éduquer une salle ou éduquer quelqu'un